now we've been through a lot and I'm
just happy he's free Teresa Giudice in
tears as she and her husband Joe joined
Andy Cohen on a special episode of watch
what happens live the sit-down
conversation happened just two weeks
after Joe was deported to Italy
following his three-year long prison
stint after pleading guilty to multiple
charges of fraud in 2014 Joe appeared
via satellite from Italy where he's
currently staying at his grandmother's
house those don't seem like happy tears
there's so much like mixed emotions I
feel but like I'm happy for my daughters
that they can FaceTime him now like I'm
just like I'm I was happy free like it
was torturous him being in there but
like mostly the last seven months while
he was in ice yes Joe nasty and like it
was mentally draining me the fate of the
couple's marriage was one of the biggest
focal points of the interview and
oppressed them on their faithfulness to
one another while they served their
respective prison sentences Joe will you
faithful to Teresa while she was in jail
I was actually yeah have you been
faithful to him yes but it seems they
have different opinions about that do I
feel like he was faithful yeah no you
don't know I don't like that she took a
photo with another man but I mean I've
asked her about the guy I mean she says
that he's I don't know this friend I
mean I don't know what kind of friend
maybe you know I don't know then there's
the question of whether they still want
to be together or if divorce is in their
future if Teresa decides to file for
divorce is there is there do you
understand why she would do that
listen as long as she's happy you know
that's all that really matters I mean
I'm not gonna you know tell her what to
do I can't you know I mean it's if she
doesn't feel like she wants to be with
me anymore than you know that's the
thing to do how we gonna live apart I
don't think like that he would be
faithful I don't I know I think he would
someone there and having me here and I
just don't want to live that life
I just don't teresa shared that their
daughters are aware of their parents
marital troubles and added that she and
the kids will not be moving to Italy
which Joe agrees with he also offered
this suggestion I could go someplace
close you know to the United States you
know a few hours away in a plane and we
could go back and forth a couple times a
week you know whatever we need to do all
right to make things work we can make
things work if we wanted to make things
work et caught up with Teresa last month
she told us how her family is doing
during this trying time drawing young
women I guess they get it from their
mommy
the reality star also weighed in on the
dramatic season 10 trailer for The Real
Housewives of New Jersey when you saw
that what was your reaction to it all
play out the trailer gives viewers a
very real look at her complicated
situation with Joe amid his deportation
case our family I mean to deal with that
in the public eye how do you deal with
that I'm used to it yeah that's what
happens when you're on TV the
double-edged sword
[Music]